presidents Lindsay has expressed his
gratitude for what we've done on a
number of occasions and not least in his
incredibly moving address that he made
to Parliament earlier this year and he's
done so again to me as he has done
countless times when I've met him so I
know he and his people are incredibly
grateful for the support the UK has
shown the welcome that we provided to
many Ukrainian families but also the
leadership that we've shown throughout
this conflict as I mentioned often being
the first to to move support forward
whether it was with the provision of
Tanks or indeed long-range weapons and
I'd say he's enormously grateful for
that but people across Ukraine are also
fighting for their lives and freedom
every single day and they're paying a
terrible price for it so I completely
understand
Vladimir's desire to do everything he
can to protect his people and to stop
this war and we will continue to give
him the support that he needs